all right this is a video for additional
examples of how to get the white cross
the first step of how to solve the
Rubik's Cube so this is basically Part B
of step one of my tutorial so what I
like to do on this step is to just go
over a few more examples of how your
Rubik's Cube might look like and how you
can more easily put the the white edge
pieces around the yellow Center okay so
let me just mix it up a little bit more
okay
so let's go with this okay so right now
there are no white edge pieces around
the yellow Center so like I said in the
first video we want to look in the
middle layer to see if we have any any
white pieces and as you can see we do
have one white piece so if it's in the
middle layer you can flip it directly up
and we know that there's no other ones
up here in these four spots that we're
going to kick out when we put it up so
we put that one next to the yellow
Center and remember don't pay attention
to the white corners because that's not
relevant to this step so again we look
in the middle layer so we'll look over
here and we find another one and if we
flip this up we're going to be turning
this piece around it will go here we
want to get an X to this yellow Center
so we flip it and now we have two pieces
up there and we have two empty spots
that we can put the white pieces into so
we'll look around and we see that there
are no further white edge pieces and the
middle layer which is okay so where are
the other two pieces well there's one
here on the bottom and there's one here
it's in the wrong orientation though it
it's on the side it's not on top okay so
what we can do is if you see a white
piece like this on bottom on the bottom
in the edge position you can actually
flip that directly up to the top as long
as you're not kicking one of the other
ones out
so if this is the piece here and it's on
this face it's on it rotates on here so
it will go here when we turn it if there
is a white piece already in that spot so
say it was like this over here and this
piece is directly above this piece when
you flip it you're going to kick that
piece out of where of the top so what
you want to do is you just want to make
sure that this spot is open the spot
directly above this this white edge
piece so by turning the top it doesn't
matter which way you turn it it's easier
to turn it to the left because there's
more empty empty spot to the left
instead of turning it 180 degrees but
either way is okay as long as you have
an empty spot above that white piece now
you can easily turn it 180 degrees until
it's on top now we see that there is one
remaining edge piece and that edge piece
is here so like I said in the first
video we want to get that edge piece
down into the middle layer to do that
you have to turn the face that the edge
piece the white color is on so it's on
this face so we know we need to turn
this face you're not going to be turning
the top because that's not going to
change the white piece to go into a spot
that we can flip it up to so what we
want to do is we want to turn it so that
it is in the middle layer and now if you
look on top the last position that is
open for a white edge piece is here
so what we do we know we're going to be
able to flip this in this direction but
if we do that we're going to kick this
one out so that we put the empty spot
directly in front of this white piece
this white piece down here that we're
going to flip up here so in order to do
that we need to turn the top face
counterclockwise now we have this empty
whites this white spot that has this
empty position here and now we could
flip it directly up
so let me mix it up one more time and
I'm going to give another example okay
so as you see on top we have no white
pieces so we look on the middle layer
here and we see we have one white piece
here that we can immediately flip up
next to the yellow Center look around
again and there are no white edge pieces
in the center in the middle layer so all
right here's a white piece what can we
do with this well like I said before if
there's a white piece that's on the side
like this you want to get it into the
middle layer so you can flip it directly
up so you have to turn the face that
this is on now you could turn it either
way you could turn it to the left like
this so that's in the it's in the middle
layer on the left or it was here so you
could turn it to the right the space
clockwise in that case and it'll be on
the right and either way it is okay so
if it's on the right you can flip it
directly up to this empty spot okay now
we look again in the middle layer and we
see that we have a free white piece here
that we could turn up to here now again
if there is a white a white edge piece
that's already on top if it's in the way
if it's in front of this piece we want
to turn it so that we have an empty spot
directly directly in front of this white
edge piece now we can flip it directly
up now there's one remaining edge piece
and it's here okay so like before we
want to get this white color this edge
piece in the middle layer so we could
turn it either way in this case I'm
going to turn it to the right but now
you'll see there's a white piece that is
occupied in this position the position
is occupied by this white piece so we
don't want to flip it up because we'll
kick that one out and we'll still
three up top there's no point so we want
to get four will put this empty spot
directly in front of you saw how it
kicked out at this position so we want
this empty spot in that position like so
now we can flip this directly up now
you'll see we have four them so
basically this this step is really about
messing around with the cube just kind
of turning it you might have white edge
pieces on the bottom you might have them
in the middle they might be up here if
they're on the bottom here you generally
can flip them directly up to an empty
spot just make sure that that empty spot
is directly above that white edge piece
that's on the bottom if it's on the top
here you want to flip it either to the
left or to the right to get it into the
middle layer then you can flip it
directly up to an empty position and
that's basically all you want to do just
to play around with you'll you'll get
the hang of it you'll understand how the
faces move and you should be able to get
these four white edge pieces around this
yellow Center and then if you want to
finish that step you can continue it on
my Rubik's Cube tutorial step one which
then shows you how to finish the rest of
the cross that you want to get here on
the bottom face which in my case is
white and as always you can send me a
message on YouTube or just reply to one
of my videos and I'll get back to you as
soon as I can with some advice alright
guys hope that helped a little more